the cdc says the highly contagious delta
variant of the coronavirus
is now in all 50 states raising new
concern
for people who are unprotected in the
five states with the lowest vaccination
rates
alabama arkansas louisiana mississippi
and wyoming less than 32 percent of the
population is fully vaccinated
that compares with more than 46 percent
of the total u.s population
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in little rock
with one notable example of who's at
risk david good morning
good morning come in and meet baby celia
we're inside the nicu
and she's starting to move around this
morning with a little beauty she is
she was born 10 weeks premature her
mother you're about to hear from didn't
quite believe covet was real and she was
against getting the vaccine
she nearly died and that's why her baby
was born premature
and she blames herself in some way now
that she survived
she has a lesson for everyone
it's a blessing that i'm still here if
it wasn't
you know for these people i wouldn't be
you think about that a lot
we do we talk about it
almost every night it's just a miracle
that
sees home and they're both alive
we met ashton reed and her husband chase
inside the hospital where she almost
died here in little rock
just felt like there was something
sitting sitting on my chest
but it got worse quickly she started to
lose oxygen
and so did her unborn baby doctors did
an emergency c-section to remove the
child
10 weeks premature ultimately they both
survived
but now she and her husband are on a
mission to educate both the kova deniers
and the anti-vaxxers they're welcome to
come talk to me and i will show them
what covett can really look like
speaking of look you literally have the
scars i have the scars to prove it
of what covid looks like ashton wrote on
facebook that doctors told her husband
she had a 40 to 50 percent chance of
surviving
she wrote i'm a healthy wife mother and
daughter and this virus almost
killed me was there a time where you
were against it yeah at the time
i was against it that's definitely
changed
the arkansas governor says that 91
percent of the active coveted cases in
this state
involve people who are not fully
vaccinated if your concern
is that the vaccine will cause problems
for you
compare 300 cova 19 positive patients
in our hospitals versus zero patients
who are in our hospitals because of
complications from the vaccine
you know what chase reed did as his wife
lay unconscious in this hospital
he went and he got vaccinated do you in
any way
feel a sense of guilt i do
feel a sense of guilt because instead of
not taking it seriously i should have
been promoting
you know getting the vaccination because
my wife was pregnant
by the way baby celia is doing really
well this morning i want to read you two
stats from the arkansas governor's
office
of the covic patients hospitalized in
this state 98
are not vaccinated for covet and 99.6
of the covid related deaths here in
arkansas involve people who were not
vaccinated
think about that boy how many more times
can we say it david thank you very much
what a story i want to point out to
people you are vaccinated because you
were standing very close to that baby it
was making me very nervous but you're
vaccinated
okay fully vaccinated i know you are i
know you are thank you david bagno